Щиро вітаємо вас це програма У фокусі
Європа від телекомпанії Deutsche Welle
війна в Україні має величезні наслідки
також і для маленької сусідньої країни
республіки Молдова
край бідна країна прийняла сотні тисяч
українських біженців і тепер зокрема в
місті лева населенню загрожує суворо
зима позаяк Молдова залежить від
російського газу
але через бажання молодого вступити до
Європейського Союзу і підтримку про
європейського курсу проти Москви Росія
постійно закриває їм газовий кран
занепокоєння щодо припинення
газопостачання велике не тільки в
дитячому будинку Левове
у їдальні ще тепло обід у дитячому
будинку у місті левова на заході
республіки Молдова
але директорка постійка боїться зими
ціни на енергоносії та харчі зростають
Вона боїться за захист і безпеку яких
хлопці та дівчата часто відчувають тут
уперше
тут Я почуваюсь безпечніше ніж удома
Тут набагато краще
Я регулярно отримую тут їжу і тепло
момент карнізм у мене вдома було
небагато чого але тут це є тут усе
зовсім інакше
Я відчуваю себе частиною сім'ї
Ці діти потрапили до нас із соціально
незахищених сімей
вони не отримують необхідного догляду
Іноді вони стають жертвами насильства
або жорстокого поводження
наше завдання захистити їх і показати їм
правильний шлях
директорка постійка звикла господарювати
з невеликою кількістю грошей але війна в
Україні у сусідній країні різко
загострила ситуацію високі ціни на
енергоносії сильно зменшують її бюджет
А зараз ми використовуємо у дитячих
кімнатах електричні обігрівачі
з палат тут у пральні Ми беремо їхній
одяг але з літа електроенергія так
подорожчала що наш дефіцит уже зараз
склав два місячних бюджетиарлінь
[музика]
ситуація у дитячому будинку відображає
ситуацію в усій Молдові про європейські
уряд країни дратує Москву тому Росія
використовує свій найсильніший важіль
впливу газ його використовують для
виробництва електроенергії У
самопроголошеному Придністров'ї що
контролюється Росією це дві третини
потреб Молдови це багато тому що
електрикою молдовани опалюють свої
будинки тролейбуси також їздять на
електриці тепер Росія вдвічі скоротила
постачання газу стверджуючи що Молдова
не заплатила панує Льодовиковий період
дерева
газпромс раніше Газпром ніколи не
припиняв постачання через затримку
платежів
зараз і серпня Минулого року відходить
до влади прийшов новий проєвропейський
уряд Ми вчасно сплатили всі рахунки
для уряду Молдови енергетична криза є
загрозою існування
це одна з причин чому президент Києва
комісії особисто поспішила до Кишинева
щоб пообіцяти бідній країні допомогу
адже нещодавно Молдова стала кандидатом
на вступ до Європейського Союзу
справжня зима ще навіть не почалася а в
леові Вона може бути довгою і холодною
вже зараз люди платять більше ніж
половину своїх доходів лише за енергію
[музика]
ми вже отримали рахунок за газ
і він здається мені занадто високим
я взяла кредит у банку і купила дрова
цього місяця я просто працюю лише на
рахунок і Кредит
скрізь важко Ми впораємось також із цим
але сподіваюся що буде легше
особливо складна ситуація для тих хто
залежить від допомоги
районна адміністрація леове якось
намагається продовжувати фінансувати
дитячий будинок
наразі витрати зросли приблизно вдвічі
Ми намагаємося робити справді все щоб
діти не
мерзлинка спорту
адже пошуки прийомних сімей для дітей
часто тривають довго
тому директорка постійка хоче дати їм
тепло домівку
ми можемо лише сподіватись що зможемо
знайти рішення щоб впоратись із високими
цінами цього року
але наразі як здається допомогти може
тільки добра фея
на конференції крім донорів для
республіки Молдова Франція Та Німеччина
пообіцяли надати додаткову мільйону
допомогу
так себе називають люди які не хочуть
сексу і цим задоволенням Німеччина з
оцінками сексуальними є майже Один
відсоток населення при цьому це число
може бути значно вище оскільки таке
явище малодосліджене та невідомо
багатьох колах постраждалі зокрема ленар
з півночі Німеччини боряться з
упередженням що А сексуальність і
начебто розладом назви є для них радше
свідомо кроком до самовизначення наших
кореспондентка зустрілися із трьома
людьми які ідентифікують себе як
асексуали
ленард живе в Гамбурзі у місті панує
відкрита сексультура на репербан є порно
кінотеатри еротичні танці на колінах і
проституція але 38-річного чоловіка це
не вражає
Це просто низькопробна картина
оголених грудей не викликає в мене
бажання підійти і помацати їх я сприймаю
це раджу як не дуже вдалу рекламу для
чогось такого чого я не розумію
те що секс не приваблює його так як
інших ленард помітив ще в період
статевого дозрівання коли всі раптом
заговорили Про це він не розумів до чого
вся ця збудженість але все одно
спробував
я не відкрив для себе що саме в цьому
має бути такого чудового чи особливого
це можливо і я не відчував огиди але
мені просто байдуже і я волію обходитись
без цього
акая виросла у сільській місцевості
поблизу білефальда у підлітковому віці
вона передусім хотіла бути як усі попри
те що вона не може насолоджуватися
сексом вона продовжує ним займатися
через соціальний тиск
скільки разів я не казала що мені це все
одно не подобається або що я все ще не
відчуваю жодного бажання відповідь
завжди була коли ти справді покохаєш і
вступиш з коханою людиною в інтимні
стосунки то тобі це сподобається
але цього не сталось
[музика]
також і Мартін із підліткового віку не
відчував бажання зайнятись сексом
оскільки він не знав тоді Що відчуває
він шукав інші причини
Я вже думав що може є Гей якщо дівчата
мене не приваблюють це мають бути хлопці
ми нічого іншого немає Кожна людина
повинна мати якийсь сексуальний потяг
але через деякий час я зрозумів що це не
так
для 30 років ленард також з'ясував що
асексуальність існує через кілька років
він у цьому зізнався Сьогодні він живе
без сексу і незручностей які з ним
пов'язані
відтоді він не шукає класичного
партнерства жінкою тому друзі чи то
чоловіки чи жінки особливо важливі для
нього
буває так що я помічаю що люди важливі
для мене але це не означає що через це
з'являється бажання бути з ними постійно
або вступати у якісь класичні стосунки
Я зовсім не хвилююсь коли знаєш що ця
особа вже може бути зв'язана стосунками
[музика]
з Мартіном було інакше навіть якщо він
не мав сексуального потягу Він завжди
хотів постійного партнерства
Він познайомився зі своєю дружиною на
вітрильному човні коли йому було за 20
довгий час вони не займалися сексом
люди завжди розповідають що кохання і
секс нероздільні єдине ціле але це повне
нісенітниця
є так багато людей які займаються сексом
не кохаючи інакше побічні будинки
вимерли і чому кохання стосунки не
можуть існувати без сексу
просто для стосунків Він не є
необхідністю
такая теж хотіла партнерства Сьогодні
вона щаслива змерле
обидві не займаються сексом вони хочуть
шити разом костюми
[музика]
вони познайомились через вебсайти
знайомств де обидві заявили що вони
асексуальні і шукають також асексуальну
партнер
якби це була зараз якась несексуальна
особа то мені б довелося попросити цю
людину утримуватись від сексу
мені просто це не подобається ми за цим
не сумуємо тож це не жертва для нас і
так я почуваюсь краще
[музика]
Мартін і його дружина не мають
регулярного сексу
Вона приймає його асексуальність але це
не означає що вони не близькі
[музика]
справа не в тому що я чому я дружина
проти дотиків я завжди кажу що ми
щовечора засинаємо в обіймах
але це ніколи або дуже-дуже рідко
призводить до того що можна було б
справді назвати сексом Це просто не
потрібно
і нам цього не бракує
Леонард Мартін
акая
ці троє живуть своєю асексуальністю дуже
по-різному але усіх їх об'єднує одне
вони не хочуть щоб хтось пояснював їм що
таке інтимність
[музика]
на нього поки що ступали тільки
американці і останній був там майже 50
років тому
втім уже незабаром на місяць висадяться
перші європейці
деякі європейські астронавти зараз
інтенсивно готуються до нової місячної
місії а саме на канарському острові
лансароти
зрозуміло що найкращою передумовою для
такої місії є ретельно підготовка і
схожий на місячний вулканічна
ландшафтного сороти пропонує всі
відчуття
[музика]
лансероти підготовка до спільної
місячної місії американців і європейців
Саме тут адже Цей острів Так схожий на
місяць і на Марс куди полетять пізніше
тут присутні німецькі астронавт
Александр герст перспективний кандидат
для цих місій
можеш повернути лезо на 20 градусів
навчання завжди спрямоване на пошук
певних каменів каменів які можуть
розповісти історію
Ми хочемо дослідити Чи маємо ми часом у
космосі братів і сестер і чи не
збереглися можливо деякі частини цього
життя в печерах на Марсі які можуть
забезпечити цілком зручні життєві умови
оскільки температура там може бути вище
нуля градусів а також там є захист від
радіації про це дуже цікаво дізнатися
тож коли ми политимо на Марс то
придивимося до них уважніше і тоді
можливо дізнаємося чи наповнений Всесвіт
життям
але спочатку політ на місяць ймовірно
Через 3-4 роки
земля дайте нам знати чи створювати нам
тут радіочастотний ресурс тоді
астронавти будуть підтримувати постійний
радіозв'язок із вченими на землі вони
повинні допомогти шукати конкретні
камені більш прицільно ніж це було
можливо під час місій Аполлон 50 років
тому
місяць схожий на розгорнутий підручник з
історії ми можемо побачити там породи
вік яких 3,8 млрд років таких порід на
землі більше немає хоча історія у нас
однакова але місяць не руйнується так як
земля внаслідок поверхової ерозії
цього тижня на алансароти вони постійно
вправляються у пошуковій роботі після
висадки на місяць
Бачиш це ось тут дуже гарно
потім контакт із науковцями місяць земля
чи підходить це місце для забору зразків
гірських порід
я прийняв рішення взяти про ви тут
дайте нам знати в іншому разі ми
піднімемося до краю кратера
але потім астронавт Олександр герст
шукає шлях до іншого кратера
радіозв'язок з тренерською командою
обривається тепер бракує інформацію
Хтось мене чує
Алекс ти мене чуєш
лансероте у нас проблема але потім
Олександр герст прибуває до місця
призначення із запізненням на годину ми
звикли що в нас на землі є скрізь
супутникові приймачі Всюди є зв'язок але
на Місяці нічого Чого немає Ми повинні
мати власні навігаційні системи власні
системи зв'язку їх треба перевіряти Тому
це ідеально Якщо є можливість
протестувати всю систему
далі на острові продовжується огляд що
має лансероти з того що шукатимуть
астронавти під час своєї місії на Місяці
інший аспект ми дивимося на кратер від
ударів метеоритів щоб побачити скільки
їм років який розподіл у часі щоб
з'ясувати настільки високим є для нас
землян ризик падіння метеорита на землю
ми знаємо що це буває але не можу
впевнено сказати наскільки високо є
ймовірність цього
І скільки важливо наберегтися Ми повинні
дослідити це на Місяці щоб мати
можливість краще захистити землю
Олександр герст вже перебував у космосі
упродовж одного року востаннє він був
командиром на міжнародній космічній
станції там він Провів понад сотню
експериментів наступний ще більший може
відбутись уже незабаром подорож на
місяць щоб побудувати там станцію
будівництво дослідницьких санкцій на
Місяці таких як уже існують в Антарктиді
буде складним завданням оскільки багато
Ми взяли з собою не можемо ми повинні
навчитися жити екологічно
використовувати ті ресурси які є на
Місяці можливо розщеплювати воду на
повітрі для дихання та паливо роботи
багато але ми до цього готуємося
як зараз 6 днів поспіль
це тренування на лансероти було не грою
каже На завершення Олександра герст
якщо ви коли-небудь побуваєте в
Копенгагені захочете відкрити для себе
щось пози туристичними дорогами Тоді вам
слід заглянути до Андерсона Він має
крамницю в центрі столиці Данії яка вас
справді зачарує Андерсен у формі квіти а
саме компонує коване листя і справжніми
квітами і настільки майстерно що назва
продавець квітів була б для нього мабуть
образою не зовсім підходить також і
назва флорист можливо краще художник і
перфекціоніст
Це була програма У Фоксі Європа від
телекомпанії Deutsche Welle
Дякуємо за ваш інтерес всього найкращого
До нових зустрічей в ефірі
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив переклад Володимира та Олесі
Швед режисер Павло Тимченко так читали
Олена потоцька Юрій Лисенко та Олесь
гоян Київ 2022 рік
[музика]